welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown to the
trailer for season 4 of the boys where
we are seeing homelander truly at the
height of his power and too many people
in the broader public okay with this
fatherson execution tradition and what
looks like an election season season
playing into how much men love the Roman
Empire so I'm going to break down some
details that you might have missed in
this trailer and point out what we have
most to look forward to and what most to
dread about the boys season 4 and by the
way this video will contain spoilers for
the boys seasons 1 through 3 as well as
the spin-off of gen V hey you have all
been paying for that Amazon Prime free
two-day delivery you've had access to
boys content for all these months so if
you skip the show and he get spoiled by
something in this video that's on you my
friend okay this trailer opens on
homelander alone in his patriotic
apartment in bot Tower we don't see his
face here but this trailer ends with his
face where it's completely covered in
blood because you know what this is a Bo
someone has to be completely head to toe
covered in blood throughout this opening
section we hear this voiceover narration
Rome Greece all democracies fail because
people are stupid these words are
actually coming from Sister Sage a new
member of the seven played by Susan
Hayward more about her in a bit but
again Roman Empire my friends I am
always amazed at how the producers of
the boys can just like jump on social
trends this fast historically speaking
this is a bit of an overstatement it's
not just that people were dumb there's a
lot of like societal and Military
factors to consider for why Roman
democracy failed and why Greek democracy
failed but she does have a point that
with Rome they did like willingly
surrender power over to Julius Caesar
and anytime character talk about whether
democracy is like a temporary experiment
that is doomed to fail you know that
there's like a fascist undercurrent to
that conversation we do see vot Tower
here that's still under reconstruction
after the events of the season 3 finale
of the boys where one of Soldier Boys
power wiping out blasts go off as ma
pushed him out of the building we see
Billy butcher walking around an old
dilapidated Bot video store this
universe's Blockbuster Video RP and
that's partially thanks to Big streamers
like Netflix and Amazon Prime I like to
think that Blockbuster was like a
historical experiment that failed just
because people had no future foresight
for the way Society was changing there's
a display for a movie featuring polarity
which is a direct notd to genv polarity
was the soup that we were introduced to
in that show the father to Andre
Anderson both of them having magnetic
powers that we learned later on in that
season does irreparable damage to their
nervous system gen V takes place between
seasons 3 and four of the boys ties
directly into that universe and gen V
ended with homelander arriving on the
gulan University campus and quelling
that Riot but citing against Marie and
kind of chastising her for turning
against her own kind and setting up for
what we're going to see in this season
of the boys which is soups and people
who support soups kind of elevating them
to like a higher status within Society a
lot of fantasy universes are grim and
dark but lately I just want to spend
some time somewhere bright and pleasant
which is why I was so excited to
discover top troops top troops is a
brand new mobile RPG with a really fun
mix of strategy merge mechanics and
massive battles top troops is also
really good at scratching that
progression itch letting you build up
your city and collect troops I'm really
enjoying top troops and I think you will
too you can download top troops Now by
using the link in the description or by
scanning the QR code and you'll get 100
gems to spend in the game and a size l
king chest on this standy though the
tagline under polarity appears to say
something like from attraction to action
and I think it's called Static heat 3
there're also posters for the seven and
big Crazy Love 2 that one featuring
termite that's a soup that can get
really really small and if he sneezes in
the wrong time he can really mess up
your day Victoria Newman appears at a
campaign rally where she's running for
vice president on the Dakota Bob singer
presidential ticket he is the US
Secretary of Defense and he considered
putting soups in the military but
Victoria Newman of course is secretly a
soup with the ability to control blood
much like Marie on genv but she is an
expert at weaponizing it to the point of
popping people's heads and there's just
something about seeing all these
balloons fall that makes me think are
they going to do a bit here where like a
balloon pops and then we don't really
know for a second if it's a head popping
or a balloon popping I just don't like
popping orbs in the room with Victoria
Newman homelander knows knows this about
Victoria Newman and he's using this
knowledge to keep Newman under his
control she also has a daughter of her
own that she gave compound V to and with
homelander as a threat to both her and
her child she's going to have to play
her cards pretty carefully she has
managed to do this in the past getting
her own adopted father Stan Edgar pushed
out from being VA CEO next we see
Starlight and huie walking out of New
York City's 21st Precinct Police Station
Starlite officially torched her uniform
and left the seven in season 3 of the
boys maybe they think the police could
do something about soups well they
probably know better than that but
Starlight raises her hand and lighting
up the area looks like reporters are
gathered outside so it kind of seems
like this was like a performative press
conference we know this season that
Starlight is going to be elevated to a
rival political figure to homelander we
see this shortly after at a vot branded
rally where there are two sides a group
of yellow dressed Starlight supporters
to the left and homelander stands to the
right now what's crazy about this though
is if you look at the wide shot there
are way more media and onlookers who are
aligned with neither side which I just
think is such an interesting political
statement from the show that the people
at the fringes the people who you see
screaming at rallies are not
representative of the vast majority of
Americans they are just who make the
news and because we point the cameras at
them that's what encourages their bad
behavior I'm not saying that type of
crazy doesn't exist it's just the media
plays a huge role in dividing Us by
focusing on it so much now we got to
talk about the Deep eyeballing this
octopus who is a little deep figurine at
the helm of a ship steering wheel in
this aquarium remember homelander Force
the Deep to eat his friend/ buddy
Timothy the octopus in season 3 he
longingly touches his finger at the
glass as he octopus reaches out to meet
it a quick shot of mother's milk and
butcher at truth con 2024 the tagline on
a banner behind them says there are no
conspiracies or coincidences they walk
past a soldier boy booth that has a
small poster that reads Secrets Revealed
soldier boy was held captive by the CIA
fren he walks in an empty Factory with
boxes of Jitter Bean Coffee company
around him the next shot shows Kimo
seemingly in the same Factory creeping
around there is a real life Jitter Bean
Coffee Company the logos are slightly
different though down from the ground
level now we see the two groups of
protesters from opposite sides of
barricade but now they're in front of
the New York County Courthouse the side
on the right keep America safe signs
with homelanders face the other side
fight like a girl follow the light I
won't be silent any longer resist with
starlight's face I assume this is
homelanders murder or manslaughter trial
that was teased in genv and it's
probably not going to be that big a deal
to homelander but just to be a good
citizen he's going to go through the
motions of and again I'm just in awe of
the producers of the show for the way
they are aiming to saiz real life
headlines it's scary how well this show
is paralleling the real world but this
two-sided protest erup into the violence
and while Starlight looks horrified at
it he can see homelander tucked away
just smiling at the madness this
sequence ends with this whole speech
about democracy being confirmed to come
from Sister sage and homelander asks
like Caesar and she responds like Caesar
I think we have to acknowledge though
that that didn't end well historically
for Caesar either it's clear that
homelanders determined to fill the ranks
of the seven with some like-minded soups
in the past fellow seven members like me
even Starlight have stood in his way and
even tried to eliminate homelander
entirely but now that he is without
leash homelander wants to get everything
he wants and be fully in command
homelander holds Ryan's hand and lifts
it up triumphantly as they're both on
stage with the other members of the
seven and what looks like a Boy Choir
behind them we see the new members being
added to the seven firecracker and
sister Sage these are both original
characters of the show firecracker is
being played by Valerie Curry she seems
to be hosting a show called Truth bomb
that I assume is on the bot Network she
has a belt buckle with a gun and a
bullet clip and has a Bandelier of
bullets across her chest she comes out
playing an air horn and yeah I'm kind of
getting some Lauren bobert vibes from
her I don't know we'll see what
firecracker can do I wonder if she has
like some ability to like Bend bullets
or stop bullets or some kind of control
over metal or black powder or something
like that or maybe just a figure like
Jubilee who can create like fireworks
and Sparks out of her hands sister Sage
if we're drawing more political
parallels that'll piss off some of you I
feel like there's some Candace Owens
Vibes there quick shot of Jeffrey Dean
Morgan greeting Billy butcher there's a
quick shot of firecracker performing at
what looks like a nativity concert or
pageant I think those are the three wise
men that's the star that's the donkey at
the Nativity manger and I think it's fun
to see fire CER in this role because
Starlight if you remember used to
perform in concerts like this back in
season 1 so I think they're bringing
firecracker in as kind of like an
annoyance to Starlight like starlight's
going to be like you're just trying to
replace me with someone who does exactly
what I do but her name is firecracker
she's just like the alt-right
conservative Starlight the Deep black
noir and at train post or pictures in
bot Tower looks like at train in the
Deep might just be back in homelanders
good graces now yes blackm is supposed
to be dead but it looks like they just
put someone else in the suit and they're
not saying anything the boys official
social accounts have acknowledged there
is no context here yet and Jessica
Clemens had a fun theory that they
cloned homelander and used some of
storefronts DNA let us know who or what
you think the New Black nor is there's a
quick shot of a male soup kind of
splitting into two he's wearing a shirt
that says Starlight is something could
be good could be bad but assuming this
guy can kind of like split into clones
of himself I like how gross and graphic
they make it look and I like how one of
them is smiling and one of them is like
just really in pain with it as butcher
drinks some booze on his Temple you can
see something squirming under his skin
that kind of looks like it could be the
side effect of compound V that he took
before or it kind of seems like we're
seeing some other kind of like fungal
toxin in this season reminding me a lot
of HBO as the last of us like that could
be the result of some of the more
graphic gross superpowers that we see in
this trailer with the little girl
attacking Kimo quick shot of vot CEO
Ashley Barrett asking some men who wants
their FS crushed and the man of the
grand goes to me the evolution of Ashley
Barrett on all these shows has just been
a fascinating watch kind of like the way
in season 1 the CEO had to do these
little power moves to keep homelander in
check but also a way to kind of like
psychologically maintain her power this
is something that Ashley Barrett now has
to do now there's a really cool moment
where homelander just takes off into
flight and he lets out this like derin
scream or
snarl I love this sound just these
little private moments with Anthony star
he that's where he does the best acting
on this show it's the only time you
really see his true self this shot of a
train with this jar of whatever these
roots are tendrils are is what I'm
talking about with this possible fungus
plot line like vot maybe incubating some
way to do like mind control or something
like that this jar that atain it's
looking at could also contain someone's
hair it's kind of hard to tell what it
is but I'm hoping it's not like
homelander hair that it's going to be
used for like a DNA cloning purposes
let's just hope that it's some of alipa
Ashley's Hair Ryan is following in
Papa's footsteps and throwing this man
in the side of the building in front of
onlookers completely splattering his
body but if you look closely there is
this girl in pigtails in the foreground
kind of wonder if Ryan Justified it as
in he was like protecting this girl
maybe this girl was like hey this is
just my dad who was just trying to like
take me home early from something I just
have a feeling that Ryan is going to
have a hero complex but like doesn't
fully know the weight of being a hero
like his dad never really truly did and
we with this clip with jeffardy Morgan's
character the boys o who came up with
that [__] I mean having the Butcher and
Negan in a show together I mean this is
just like perfect Kismet I I'd love that
these two are in a show together I want
to know from you what kind of character
do you think Jeffrey Dean Morgan is
playing he is like a heavyweight they
must have some amazing role for him but
for now we don't know too much the
trailer ends with homelander covered in
blood as he rides an elevator alone but
he smiles this Sinister smile I'm really
really excited for season 4 it's coming
at some point in 2024 and don't forget
to click the link in the description or
scan the QR code to download top troops
today top troops is a brand new mobile
RPG with a really fun mix of strategy
merge mechanics and massive battles top
troops is also really good at scratching
that progression itch letting you build
up your city and collect troops I'm
really enjoying top troops and I think
you will too you can download top troops
Now by using the link in the description
or by scanning the QR code and you'll
get 100 gems to spend in the game and a
size l king chest let me know in the
comments below what you're most looking
forward to from this season big thanks
to everyone on the new rockstars team
for helping jump on this video early on
Saturday morning I'm currently in and
out of work right now as I'm headed out
on paternity leave so I'm not going to
be on the channel as much in the month
of December but you'll still see me
around in some other videos Jessica
Clemens is coming back to help cover for
me during this time thanks to all of you
for watching subscribe to all three
channels of the new rockstars Network
and I'll see you soon
[Music]
fine